president Reza PAF irawan has made it
clear his forces won't stop hundreds of
thousands of Syrian and other refugees
from trying to get into Europe I'm going
to Europe because I want to continue my
education I stopped my education in
Syria and work here in Turkey isn't
great my salary is barely enough life is
better they will have health care and
many other opportunities we don't have
identity cards nothing hospitals don't
treat us they don't give us medicine the
bosses take our money sometimes don't
pay our salaries we don't have residence
permits we have many problems in a
24-hour period Greece said it had
stopped four thousand migrants from
entering and for sending reinforcements
to secure its land and sea borders the
situation is now difficult and
unpleasant thousands of suffering people
are amassing at our borders they don't
come here by themselves a neighbor
turkey is pushing them away and using
them we want to send a message to all
that we will let no one get in without
legal travel documents Greece has
borders Europe has borders and as these
borders that we Greeks are guarding in
Istanbul for a second day free buses
were provided for those wishing to take
their chances at the border amid the
crowd there were also Afghan and Iranian
migrants this isn't the first time
president Erdogan has cleared the way
for refugees to head to Europe's borders
since the start of the war in Syria
Turkey is fighting for control of the
last rebel-held area in Eid Lib and
warning its greatest loss of soldiers
heard wons message is clear he wants
NATO on the battlefield with Turkey and
Europe needs to help with the Syrian
refugee crisis
Natasha guy named al Jazeera and earn a
turkey near the border with Greece